alors les sapins tous les ans certains
entreprises comme Ikea ou Truffaut nous
offrent les sapins qui n'ont pas pu
vendre donc ils ont récupéré et qui sont
évidemment toujours en état de verdure
pour pouvoir justement enrichir la vie
nos animaux
[Musique]
du coup on va mettre des morceaux de
bœuf et quelques épices aussi pour
stimuler les tigres donc les morceaux de
boeuf ça va sur tous les attirer parce
que c'est de la viande et c'est ce dont
ils vont avoir envie et une fois qu'ils
auront fini de manger tous les morceaux
de boeuf il restera un petit peu
d'épices sur les épines pour stimuler
leur sens olfactif
et leur changer un petit peu leur
routine quotidienne
[Musique]
les félins ils adorent ça parce que du
coup c'est très enrichissant pour eux au
niveau de l'odeur après on peut le
donner à des petits végétariens les
chèvres par exemple on peut leur donner
les lémuriens aussi ils aiment bien ça
après on demande quand même l'accord de
nos vétérinaires
[Musique]
évidemment une fois qu'ils sont terminés
une fois qu'ils ont vieillis qui sont
secs et bien on les recycle dans en
paillage et on les broie sur l'ensemble
du parc
[Musique]